[Music]
what's up party people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries the show you watch
about the other show you watch
I've spent radicular this is Joestar
hello there's Dan merle i today will be
addressing everyone's favorite film
transformers the last night boy you
voted we listened we'll be talking about
our thoughts and our process stick
around to the end you'll see what didn't
make it in some cut jokes and deleted
scenes i recorded an entire separate
video about how much I hate transformers
is called a haterade you could be on
this same channel but what do you what
do you guys think how do you guys know
this we man I sometimes it's hard to
write an honest trailer cuz what it's so
good what do you say about the film and
you got no no can't this is the dirt
movie it hits me on a lot of levels
because I like my plastic robots that
turn into stuff and yeah it hurts it
feels like he's personally attacking me
well this is yeah it's tricky and and
you'll go in one second but I just want
to say that it's a target-rich
environment writing a Transformers
honest trailer you almost it overloads
you with crap that yes don't know where
to aim
ya know it's I almost walked out of
transformers 4 I was very tempted to
walk out of this one having to review
both of them was what kept me in my seat
both times and it's yeah it's it's but
it's also strange in that it's not it's
not like a Shyamalan thing where it's
like it's trying to be something so hard
and just failing at every turn
it doesn't even try which is what pisses
me off the most
it's just the lack of any attempt at
storytelling or coherence it's literally
just like sit down you idiot stuff
popcorn in your face and watch this
garbage guess what I'm gonna make five
more and you're gonna watch that one too
everyone dies or nothing matters yeah
get out here but the audience to their
credit caught on with this one largely
yeah tanks in the u.s. made just over
under thirty million dollars in like I
think was
like a four or five hundred million
dollar drop-off worldwide so the
audience largely did find it took five
of five of these
but somehow the audience I do maintain
that they cut together in really good
trailers but you can't make a movie out
of trailer mouths out of just the
biggest exploding scenes the biggest
yelled lines when the entire movie is at
that level it's dumbing it's numbing
yeah but it's both it is this one was
frustrating too because after for these
things the the fifth trailer was
actually so weird that I was like okay
like King Arthur was in a and oh wow I
was like are they yeah and then I
remember the last one they're like oh
there's dinosaurs in this one okay maybe
they cracked it no no none of the things
none of them and there's so for me five
there so because you need to have the
random military subplot you need to have
the kids you need to have the
transformers you need to have the zoo
blah blah or whatever yeah Jhansi does
sprouts and every moving scrotum now
apparently is a requirement this
actually this one didn't start out as
bad as others I think that I was kind of
like okay this is pretty straightforward
until about halfway through and then
they go through every single yeah
nonsense
situation imaginable and we're in London
we're on a sub there's AB robot there's
a butler this is submarine we're under
in space there's no gravity the cameras
doing this and the cameras doing this
flags yes God yeah no this this movie
this movie hurts and it like abandons
what it wants to do like almost scene by
scene because the beginning of the movie
you're like oh cool Earth has like like
cool advanced technology cuz I got the
Robocop things walking around those
disappear and then yeah that just goes
away and it's just it's just the cast of
the rock
jumping out of a helicopter or something
no no no that's nothing ma'am a big to
an hour and 45 minutes Chunkin nothing
bagel nothing so I mean we could pick
into the minutiae but that's the the you
walk away not knowing what happened
right to you for you it's like a fugue
state big question now is how do they
actually make these because they're so
visual effect heavy there's got to be a
lot of previz for this but there's it
seems like there's no script it's all
previz right it's all previous but how
do you do it seems like there's no words
that were put on a page I don't know I
think I don't I think Michael is just
put together dictates into like Siri or
something just like Optimus Prime yeah
that's what they get is that audio file
and then they're like okay it's making
like a helicopter noise right here's
order 50 helicopters please 60 60 make
it an even 60 yeah yeah okay no that
answers that question really well yeah
right well let's dive into the thing
where hopefully the last time but it
won't be
transform and roll time I wasn't here
there are 17 newbies you wanted us to
make an honest trailer for and now your
number one choice Wow
you guys clearly hate us
[Music]
after every Transformers movie there is
hope hope that they won't make another
one now the bay bots are back for his
final chapter until they return up to 14
more times oh he says he's coming he's
done every time and every time he's
retired after the third to the fourth
right after the first one he was like I
don't know the writers strike I don't
think I'm gonna move on to something
else yes I'm done
no I've actually pushed through
heroically pushed through the writer's
strike to get revenge of the Fallen
although with the writing process you
just came up that means there are 14
audio files of him just yelling sounds
and his cone it's like look out it's
Soundwave and he's got the shit's Taco
Bell
sponsor get the sponsor fun so that
we've got a poop Rumble frenzy ravage
Ratbat wipe my ass sold yeah where you
say day I don't know I don't know let's
keep everything hurting transformers the
last night strap in for another
Shakespearean tale in the sense that
it's a tale told by an idiot full of
sound and fury signifying nothing but
you can bet your life there'll be some
big-ass explosions
while to moderate racism hey chief
my name is Sherman it's okay to be a kid
little Chino an action that looks like
to RadioShack sweatsuit rebirth but
where do Decepticons learn Ebonics like
in universe Joe well hi Jess from Jess
nice movie I think down this universe
what they're saying is that when the
Germans invaded England after Rome they
all spoke Ebonics and that's where the
Decepticons learned it around this King
Arthur times Oh God well we'll get to
that in a second yeah yeah also the the
line of like doing Kama Sutra and a
hurricane we're running out of ways to
describe what it looks like the
favorites fighting my favorite is still
two junkyards having sex with each other
yes yes yeah so variations on a theme
we'll run out of analogies eventually
keep playing industry and action that
looks like two radio shacks doing Kama
Sutra in a hurricane
how we doing we don't yet know still
going huh forget everything you knew
about the Transformers because so did
Michael Bay who in the third one said
Cybertron was destroyed and in this one
said actually it's back in the fourth
one said Megatron is now Galvatron and
then this one said never mind
he's Megatron again and in the first one
said the Transformers came to earth to
find the Allspark and learn English from
the internet but in this one said you
know what
they were allies with King Arthur and
one of them killed Hitler has to watch
the kill Hitler see we're not the only
ones insulting the intelligence of
transformers movie fans so is he
positive it's not ambiguous
what isn't did not write the first movie
in any ambiguous way they're making a
safe bet that you forgot what happened
in these bushes
they won't remain very safe bet but
again it goes back to the not trying
philosophies like it wasn't like they
retcons something and we're like you
know we kind of set up this continuity
but we figured out a way around it it's
just like no they don't care no they
don't care that they set things up
they're just like I don't I don't care
about you I don't care about this
franchise or the story enough to even
attempt this is where you go down like
an insane K hole because you could be
like well then also in this movie why is
no one in human history realized that
the earth is a robot is the entire no
one ever notice a robot yeah I don't
think cuz a lot of people be like first
second we're okay but I let's see now I
don't think they were one right oh I
really think that like we just weren't
ready to process this kind of contempt
and so we just didn't know who we were
watching in the first one this first one
usually there wasn't the worst thing in
the world and was not the worst thing in
the world
yeah and it beat us into submission yep
but we're not staying he's just warming
us up with the hate this woman said if
the King Arthur x thing really throws me
for a loop because King Arthur first of
all didn't exist but that's fine it's
transformers universe but then it's like
who's King Arthur fighting in England
that the Transformers are like picking
sides on oh yeah it was the Saxon the
Sexson she eventually won right yeah so
they did where were they in the long run
yeah why would the treads remind me why
the Transformers like pick decide in
that cuz Merlin told us to Marilyn
truck it would really help it would do
him a solid yeah he said it was the end
of the world and that is the the forces
of evil it's really my arm you know yeah
but only a few hundred square miles
at that point keeping in mind that the
transformer dragon did not reimburse
it stayed with the body of Merlin
throughout every actual evil foisted
upon the world they only decided to pop
out for what drunk stanley tucci again
yeah he was a character in the fourth
one but no now he's Merlin yeah if
you're gonna go there like just go crazy
in the cartoon they like went to
Atlantis and one of them fell in love
with the mermaid it was stupid so just
do that and I think they've done Foley's
do no not until Optimus Prime seduces a
mermaid have they gone fully stupid ass
well soon enough it's not about that
Danny more than
the Transformers version of that would
be about yes would be about a trust your
company out of all of it Michael Bay
shape of water would only be about fish
sex banging yes a truck banging a fish
there was a mercifully little product
placement comparatively but that was a
big yeah what would the baby dinosaurs
why was that where'd they come from I
don't know yet well that's a whole can
of worms at least they weren't using
Chinese bank ATMs in Texas like they
were in the last robot Tyrannosaurus Rex
didn't do any that you don't you
it's like he's will just go in the
darkest timeline prepare for another
Transformers movie that's mostly about
the humans Cade Yeager is back and he's
still an inventor I'm an inventor that
still from Texas they have the support
of the entire world a brilliant British
uterus have you found a man yet risen
you're always single what generic
military guys yelling generic military
things yes used to be Josh Duhamel
what about family man now who is it
Justin well okay and that beer dad
general Morshower
which is his actual name is Glenn
Morshower and his character is like
general Mortimer they're just like he's
got the same name now there's like
parties to the military there's like the
military and then like like a private
military but they write enemies than
their friends and their enemies and
their friends there's the private
transformers military which I believe
Josh Duhamel was implanted in as a spy
cuz he's in the actual metal and they're
spying on Megatron but he skipped over
so much in this because there's so much
dumb stuff like Megatron
like has a list of demands before he'll
work with them and it's yes release my
transformer friends and one of his
transformer friends is a bank robber and
I was like what does it Decepticon need
with
what is it what is he gonna spend it on
have you even told it does he have a
wallet does he have a Scott is waistline
like transforms into a fanny pack it's a
money belt
here's the money yeah it's got solid
money belt well what does he buy and
they all get their own little picture
O's with names and then they're all
never killed yeah and they're the stupid
red BOTS and like with the chain I just
assumed that that was like extended
universe stuff to people it's like
there's like 250 ridiculous character
names and you're like and one of them
sounds like ki gagger I can't even
remember what soos Maximus Zeus or some
come on man yeah come on there's a
decepticon named spinister
cuz he's sinister and he has spinning
parts and that's brilliant makes sense
yeah he's not your mo free robot puns
aren't hard come on come on kids keep in
mind that nothing in this trailer as far
as had anything to do with Optimus Prime
did the movie for whatever reason it's
like you have robot dinosaurs an Optimus
Prime these are the two things that you
have going for you yeah
robot dinosaurs Optimus Prime let's not
use either one of them stick with it
stick with the basics all right we gotta
know more about Cade Yeager keep going a
random street urchin so I'm currently
gonna be there even she doesn't know why
she's here and Anthony Hopkins who
delivers a brief portrayal of a man who
won an Oscar and then realized he's
doing a Transformers movie my own family
had something some omen it hits them
I love this because before and after
scene he's not crying at all and then
just randomly they just cut in a take
where he was on the verge of tears
though but right before and right after
he's completely jolly and I just loved
it he has a whole big room that's like
here's all the secrets wit Wickham
they're not in a safe yeah they're not
in a pyramid there's just a big old
Downton Abbey rooms because he has a
robot Butler that was like it broke down
here's all of the Vinci's coats and the
tank remember the tank oh oh sorry the
tank he's just got a tank that never
shows up again right he's got like the
old Sparky vet
and hot rod and the Bentley that's
Vivian Whibley owns that I guess planted
because he goes it's just like it's time
my friend and then yeah I did then it
just drives her to stop just stop just
stop all of the movie there was one
there was one thing you could have done
in this movie to make fans go okay and
that was half Judd Nelson voice hot rod
that was the one thing you needed to do
he voiced him in the movie in the old
animated movie how red was the French
yeah the French thing a really French
one in the world in the cartoon and
stuff he's literally he's a hot-headed
teen type character because his name's
hot rod yeah not wrong and he does he
have a gun that shoots slow-motion in
the cartoon
it's okay Sir Anthony at least shooting
in peed on by bumblebee person is pretty
good you guys the rage-fueled violent
Decepticons are back and the only things
that can stop them are the rage fueled
violent Autobots I am killing burn you
so bad yo but she died as a child and
their rage fueled a violent human allies
one of my favorite honest trailer notes
of all time as I wrote down on my sheet
Mark Wahlberg threatens to punch child
and face right below Anthony Hopkins
yells at Asia whatever Anthony Hopkins
yells at Asian tourists yeah I'm not
sure if either of them knew that those
were actors no yeah they did not realize
there was a hot set yeah no there's
there visiting very ver Tay let's keep
going the punch of the Facebook really
hard
caught in the middle is Optimus biscuits
never seen Ryan and help Thomas Prime
hi I'm Optimus Prime we get it
hi I'm Optimus Prime he's been forced by
a lady with dreads to turn against his
family and if you said that's the exact
plot of fate in the Furious
congratulations you saw some really bad
movies and 26 deal from the best scene
across a two-and-a-half hour runtime is
Optimus good is he bad do I care
or is he go for half the movie why is
there kung-fu robot Butler am i high
what do words even mean anymore
I don't see him he yeah what would even
transform into what would count a teapot
mode you want your Butler to transform
into well it's like it's more how that
transformers work again they take on
other shapes but like vehicles right
yeah watches yeah once some can be guns
yeah o'clock yeah she should be
Cogsworth from beauty in the culture
called townsman Coxon hath very
different codes with non Mexican Union
equivalent non-union Mexican Michael
babe apparently just love Downton Abbey
and was like you know what you know
people love if the butler from Downton
Abbey new comfort clean a butler
yeah that's the the height of creativity
is like who played a butler he should
play the butler Google who played a
butler you know this film is one Jeff
Bridges short of a Big Lebowski reunion
Oh
Goodman Buscemi Buscemi yeah I think
Buscemi we didn't call this out every
transformers voice is altered in some
type of robot way Steve Buscemi is just
talking they do not do any treatment of
his boy there's no filter on his voice
no no no although on that Lebowski
reunion I will come back and watch one
of these if flea voices a deceptive
yeah but like as that Kraftwerk style
yeah the nihilist decepticon yeah take
her Johnson yeah
Nile Tron and so it turns into a synth
alright let's keep going
more so roll out with a franchise
Michael Bay is so bored with he's
literally making characters out of
garbage builds up the importance of
bumblebees voice only tool even the temp
audio from his sound engineer sting like
so much this week for the entire boobie
god I cannot unsee that in this it fury
aided me more than any other thing in
this movie you shoot a movie in an
aspect you shouldn't multiple aspect
ratios find Chris Nolan does that did it
with Dunkirk Dark Knight totally fine
you have sequences in IMAX you have
sequences that are in an IMAX he's go
between so well but double bars pop in
you go to IMAX I pop out you're doing
that for five minutes of bars pop back
in ten more minutes that's fine no
problem
Michael Bay would shoot parts of one
scene in three three not two three
different aspect ratios IMAX and then
this one and then one that was like
slightly between the two but only ever
so slightly that when you're watching it
on a screen the whole movie is doing
this Hopson no it's like my god if
you're not giving me epilepsy
with this action already the
whole time you you that is
contempt that is contempt that is
contempt for the audience that is
contempt for the artform no planning
whatsoever and I swear to god he did it
on purpose yeah
preachy for each boy breach I'm sorry
I'm trying to be more circumspect about
movies yes contemptuous yeah it was
contemptuous of the audience and the
craft no one does that just stick with
the screen junkies news way and do
everything in 480p at least the potatoes
consistent yes you don't see a shooting
under nor Ida and then a french fried
and the mistake fries
only Joe's camera was like a red cam
like a like some Super HD thing and the
rest of it was you know where Tommy was
sowing it yeah I just wanted to know the
difference we should both can i unsee
that now starring Jar Jar clings silence
of the grabs the boogie night Megan pho
will orphan angry drunk adore him
Star Wars and actual quotes from the
film that perfectly describe the
transformers writers room logic has left
the building of Michael Bay set beam
personalities just crashing money a
Michael Bay script I knew it sounds an
old vaguely racist Michael Bay's answer
to everything and us after writing
another honest trailer for yet another
Transformers movie as my life will be
based have you ever felt like that sigh
robot hmm you know what's almost as
awkward is that long scene about having
sex with Mark Wahlberg's underage
daughter in the last movie and even
longer scene about how long it's been
since Mark Wahlberg had sex no Whoopi
most okay it's been a while well how
long's a while we come on the year like
because he's well we didn't even talk
about how he's the chosen night because
he gets this lake
medallion do any robot blob and vixx's
he ancient no she's a with then why does
the blob choose him cuz he was around he
was around - sure fair enough yeah he
said hi to its mother for him
alright deleted scenes that keeps
co-starring
when Paul Simpson an actual night M
stern an inventor Sparky spark I Heart
Huckabees oh yeah we're certainly will
see movies too Dora the transformer
let's not go to Camelot
tis a silly place trans franchise the
last gasp trans this I'm done mmm
loud noises part 5 revenge yeah they
could have to take a cab to take against
plans and loves like hours of Roberts
time friends fighters the last straw oh
we stick it to the plant the whole town
is wired and rigged uh I hope you told
the people that live there sloppy when
aliens arrive and ask who is Michael Bay
well show them the scene of an ethnic
stereotype robot with a gun that shoots
slow motion motion gun you know happens
yeah we lost for words cuz already did a
whole other video about how much I hate
this thing so like this is just piling
on it's the continued stop can we stop
want to do any more and they said no
they said made us we hate you yeah we
want to ruin your week is it yeah is it
cuz we changed movie because the two
fighters just why you made us is this
why you did this to us
it's the is the price we pay one fighter
the ceiling lying on the ground crying
oh man okay guys I think we've
overstayed our yeah much like this
franchise yeah we'll be back next week
there'll be another house trailer I
don't even know what it is so I can't
tease it I do
it's we talked about a ten percenter
next week's might be a ten percenter
it's it's an older movie older by our
standards
but is it aged like champagne yeah it
always greats like champagne always like
champagne
alright cool alright cool next week will
be a fun one
we hope you stick around we will and
we'll see you next week on another
honest trailer commentaries bye
[Music]
you